one thing I am actually jealous of uh
not the snakes not the spiders I'm not
jealous of that uh but it's the amount
of like but different birds you have
here oh yeah in England we have like
pigeons and seagulls I remember like the
first time I landed in Sydney I I
thought it was like a city I'm used to
like seeing some exotic birds and the
first thing I see was I believe like I
didn't know what it was I just saw a
bird with a really long thin beak I
don't know and then I look at it and I'm
like
and then Sydney's like gone what are you
looking at and then she looks at she
goes what the [__] is that
that's that's cool that's called a bin
chicken yeah
that is just the weirdest [__] thing
it is the weirdest thing they're an
absolute nuisance as well I I just can't
believe they exist
like I feel like every other country
there would have been something that
just got rid of them by accident you
know like in the UK we just have
annoying little kids they would piss
them off they'd be like oh [__] this
we're going back in the country no but
the problem with the bin chickens is
that they're so big that the kids are
like I don't want to go anywhere
toddlers it's so weird
it's because they're just like as the
name suggests they just go into the bins
and they just [__] they're basically
like our equivalent of crows I mean we
have that you know we have the the
um
what are the black birds that we have
here again magpies thank you yeah
the magpies are kind of [__] is that
true oh yeah in fact I think it's like I
read a study that said like uh magpies
were like I think number one or number
two biggest reason as to why cyclists
get into accidents
because they because there's such [__]
cons are let me tell you
magpies right they do this thing called
swooping right which is basically
they're so incredibly territorial that
if you go even in like a 10 kilometer
radius of their nest they're just like
that's a threat and they just start
swooping you and so cyclists who are
like just you know having a casual
Sunday morning cycle just gets swooped
by these magpies and they [__] go ask
over and then they [__] die just dive
bomb them yeah they dive bomb them oh my
God yeah who's been dive bombed by
Magpie before yeah thank you
yeah so kind of cyclathon in Australia
right yeah
level level impossible God is going to
turn up in a full suit of armor and he's
like okay I am ready now okay let's
let's hypothetically let's say I was
like I was stupid enough to say yes okay
and I'm I'm ready to fight off every
single dangerous animal and [__] I
can't even sleep in my hotel room
without fear of being killed by a spider
okay
your internet is so [__] [__] here
I'll be like hey guys uh well welcome
back to the stream all right I'll see
you guys in two hours when I get near a
telephone uh Tower also I okay so in
Japan right when you cycle between uh
the cities it's like everything's about
50 to 100 kilometers separate yeah in
Australia it's like all right
two days into the cycle of fun and we
still haven't left Sydney
four days in I still haven't got to the
next city maybe nine days in we'll
finally reach another city and it'll be
[__] Canberra yeah oh [__] this I'm
going home
yeah I feel I've always thought about
that like if you were to do a cyclathon
in Australia what would be like
the most optimal route because it's like
cycling from Sydney to Canberra would be
nice while you're in Sydney for the
first three days but then after that
it's like
[__] all like it's not like what I don't
know I don't know like because Australia
I mean Australia is massive yeah right
cycling isn't the most optimal way to
get around this country yeah especially
with all of the dangers that you'll have
the QuickTime events magpies yeah
exactly yeah I don't think it'll be
doable to be honest with you maybe maybe
if you like went from one end to Sydney
to the other
maybe but that wouldn't be much fun that
would be [__] yeah imagine how you'd
advertise that I cycle all of Sydney
Australians are like wow the rest of the
rest of the world is like you cycle the
city
the [__] what other kind of birds are
there here in Australia though you get
to regularly see
birds in Australia
um obviously we have cockatoos uh yeah
we just see flocks of them here yes it's
it's it's so weird because this is such
an exotic bird that you know you rarely
get to see they sound like their cry
sounds like a chain smoker trying to
hack up a loogie you know it's like ah
it's like my god when you're woken up by
that at like five five in the morning
it's just like oh my God I'm gonna kill
these birds and then uh we have the
Kookaburra as well uh which is a bird
that the cry sounds like it's laughing
what type of bird is the one you have as
a pet uh I had a cockatiel which is just
like a small it's like a baby cockatoo
no it looked like an SS tiered skin of a
pigeon
it looks so cool like our birds all suck
in the UK we just have pigeons like we
have pigeons and seagulls here but you
guys have other tears you have like SS
tear birds like this yeah you guys
actually have like a drop rate with like
different tiers of birds we have two and
they're both like one Stars yeah
seagulls and pigeons
I don't know what would be the most
exotic bird you'd see because you you
are like often come to your house for
the first time you actually convinced me
when I'm able to get one I'm definitely
gonna get a bird as a pet oh yeah like
oh I'm the best does anyone here have a
pet bird
I
have another bird story after my
previous first story involving a bird in
Thailand yeah uh I saw the saddest thing
I've ever seen in my life okay in my
entire house last month when I was
living there uh so in my entire house
it's kind of out of the city so it's
kind of like closer to the outskirts
it's closer to Nature uh so we see a lot
of wildlife there we have had massive
snakes that we've had to get rid of our
uh get rid of our snakes in our house as
well uh we we get a lot of birds as well
uh and there's one time I was just
chilling out my hammock uh in my
backyard and I see two birds in front of
me uh one's just sitting there and there
is another bird who I assume to be a
male bird doing some kind of mating
dance so he had he had his wings out
like this
kind of like this yeah just just doing
this
oh is that is that like the black birds
sorry is are they like the black birds I
think so yeah I think I know what you're
talking about yeah so he was dancing uh
in front of this other bird for a
full-on 10 minutes
uh and then after about 10-15 minutes
the other bird just flies off
and I've never wanted
flew off yes
I've never wanted to give a bird a hug
so badly in my life because all he did
was just slowly put his wings back
didn't even fly off and just walked off
to a to a bush that's that's just me
every time I'm at a club
I danced for 10 minutes the woman walks
off and I'm like I'll get a beer that
was just like a bro moment in real life
I was like bro it's okay man it's okay
you'll find another one there's another
one don't worry there's so many stories
with animals
I'm in Australia well do you not have
any I thought one of the animals played
games and watched anime why are we why
are we interacting with someone's nature
what are the animals that you commonly
find in Wales
yeah yeah what's uh what's a Welsh part
uh past time
or what do you what do you guys do
sometimes you'll be on the train and
then it'll be like sorry there is a
sheep on the track we cannot continue
it's real that happens a lot and you're
like well how do we move it you're like
you you don't
it just moves well you don't bully the
Sheep can't be that big right you could
just get someone to just push it you
can't push a sheep they're [__] big
just get like three people to just be
like out of the way
all right good Gavin Steve
all the train conductors all right come
on let's go move this [__] they'll
eventually move
wait okay so you said you've experienced
that before right yeah many times what's
the longest you've had to wait for a
sheep to move like 40 minutes
oh my God because sometimes it's like
they bring all their friends
and they're all Crossing because
sometimes the trains go through like
someone's Farmland yeah so then it's
just like ah you're just slowly watching
them go and then they're like ah let's
go back
oh my god oh okay but yeah that happens
um other than that just it's like it's
like eventually over to like a
difficulty slider of like Wildlife yeah
Wales is like putting it all the way
down to zero and Australia is like
cranking it to ten yeah and then putting
like nightmare mode on top of it yeah
it's like we don't have anything that's
really dangerous we just had like Rams
do you guys have Rams do we have Rams
there's like a bit of really angry I
think I think we do have Rams but you'd
have to go out to like rural Australia
to find those and like no one [__]
lives out there I was like uh I was
shopping one time at this local um like
I don't know like a corner store it was
kind of far out and uh I was just there
and I went outside of the store and as I
came out of the store there was just a
ram
just on the road